Asians about what we're doing in terms
of looking at medical prices and the
prices you're paying and how you can use
strategies to try to lower the amount of
costs that you are facing especially in
bills surprise bills that you don't
expect many of you probably know already
that we've been doing this series all
week long we call it medical price
roulette and the reason we call it
roulette is because guess what you spin
the wheel you throw in the little and it
lands on a number and you don't know
what number you're gonna get well guess
what all of us have had those medical
bills where we get a bill in the mail
and we say oh look suddenly I owe $2,000
and I don't know why I owe $2,000 or
even if I know why I didn't expect to
get $2,000 I expected $200 and now the
budget doesn't afford for two hundred
thousand dollars and what am I supposed
to do you have kids you have a family
your other commitments how to handle all
this so so we've been talking telling
you stories of people who've had issues
couple of questions that we've had I
want to talk about some questions we've
had coming in we've had lots of emails
and by the way I just want to plug the
web link where you can share you the
prices that you paid with us please do
this we have now probably upwards of
four hundred and fifty shares that's
people who have come and filled out the
form and told us this is what I paid and
we want you to do that and the place to
do that is CBS news.com slash health
costs CBS news.com slash health costs
we'll put it up in the facebook comments
Brendan's going to do that for us
Brendan's behind the camera right now
and when you go to that you're gonna
click through basically you're gonna put
in CBS news.com slash health costs
you're gonna see a button sort of thing
that says share and search prices you
click on that it'll take you to kind of
an intermediate disclaimer page just
click again we know how those internet
things are and then you'll land on the
clear health costs slash CBS page where
we're collecting your prices that you
paid the
one reason we're doing that is sir
Jeannie and her team have surveyed
prices cash prices for procedures in to
markets Dallas in San Francisco but we
want to know hey you live somewhere else
what are you paying for those what kind
of insurance co-pays did you face what
did you have to pay out-of-pocket
what are these medical procedures
actually costing you so please share
that with us leave us your email and
phone number if you would or one or the
other just your emails fine if you can
if you're comfortable with that so that
maybe we can reach out to you may be of
a story you want to talk to us about for
a future CBS News CBS this morning
investigative story please do it we
would love to hear from you you can also
email us also say this at health costs
at CBS news.com now Jeannie's that ever
so patiently waiting here while I talk
so Jeannie just tell me a little bit
about the feedback that you've been
seeing from people and what are some of
the stories that you've heard from
people that have impacted you the most I
mean I know I've read a lot of them you
have to what's it what are you reacting
to oh my goodness people are out there
suffering from this we hear stories
about people who are paying thousands
and thousands of dollars one woman said
that the death that she incurred caused
her to when her son went into the
military army intelligence interviewed
her about whether this death could
present a threat of bribery
so his debt was so high in other words
this kid in the military that they
wanted to know if he could be bribed
somehow because he was facing such a
heavy debt load they might be vulnerable
right which is horrible I mean really
this is medical debt I mean since when
are people supposed to be hundreds of
thousands of dollars in medical debt to
the point where some people have to file
bankruptcy we know that's happening we
know that some people out there have had
to file bankruptcy because they couldn't
handle these crushing medical bills we
hear a lot from people who can afford
the diagnosis but not the cure so you
know what's wrong with you you can't
afford to pay for the medication you
can't afford to pay for the person
it's our breaking yeah so we are we are
hearing so much feedback from people
it's more feedback on this than probably
any other story I've done in years
because let's face it we all get these
bills I do too
do you need to do in fact I see word I
know Jeannie you don't know this about
her probably you know but she used to be
a New York Times journalist for she
works in New Year time for 25 years and
then she decided hey I'm gonna start a
company to try to answer the questions
about what anything costs in health care
like what does anything cost nobody
knows
there's no transparency really and and
nobody knows what the prices are on
anything and I know this for you started
with a personal experience didn't it
like it was something about like the
bills that you got in your family so
members of my family had three bits of
minor surgery about a half hour each
yeah 14 months apart nothing serious so
we got three sets of bills the
anesthesia alone for the first surgery
was $2,000 the second two thousand the
third one six thousand dollars right so
okay so like that's crazy how does that
in two thousand two thousand six
thousand dollars so I'm a journalist I
did some research I came to dug around
on the internets and found out that for
the expensive one we were being charged
1419 dollars for a generic anti-nausea
medication that I could buy online for
$2.49 yeah I feel like those are the
examples that really really make people
just mad because $2.49 versus $1,000
some it just doesn't make sense does it
does it seem to pass the smell test like
somebody's making money somebody made
that thousand dollars we just don't know
who right right out of the hospital you
know and the more I started to talk
about this the more I realized that
other people had similar stories and
well there is some stigma or taboo
associated with talking about medical
treatment and money like not everybody
wants to talk about those things that
feels kind of icky or they just don't
feel like they're not used to it but I
bet everybody out there listening has a
story yeah the more I started to talk to
people the more I realized that it was a
universal problem
and we are hearing that to the
universality of this problem is huge one
of these I want to mention is so you
know this morning we featured on CBS
this morning we ran a segment where we
talked about we talked to a woman who
she let us sit with her as she tried to
shop for a pair of cardiac tests that
she needed a few years ago she had these
two tests and she wound up paying $4,000
out of pocket cash after insurance she
had insurance but it wound up being four
grand out of her pocket afterwards so
she needs the test again according to
her doctor but this time she's like I'm
shopping around this time so she she's
like we said can we come listen and
watch as you try to shop around and she
said sure so we went to her house and we
showed this morning and you know it
seems really difficult and frustrating
she calls the doctor they don't know the
price which is common doctors I
oftentimes don't know what it's gonna
cost you because you have insurance or
you don't or you're paying cash you're
not or you're in a financial assistance
program so you're pay almost nothing
whatever it is so then they said we'll
call the lab and ask them so then the
lab was like no called a financial
counselor and then the financial
counselor she leaves a voicemail and
then you know how that is maybe they get
back to you you know so I feel like some
people think what gosh like can I even
do it can I even shop around so what do
you tell people when they are trying to
shop around for prices how can you do
that without spending hours and hours
and hours and being completely
frustrated with it right so we have a
little handbook about that that will be
going up on the site I hope today but
basically what we tell people is find
out the cpt code the exact name and the
procedure code there should be a
procedure code attached to it then
called the hospital clinic lab doctor
whatever and say I I want to know what
this will cost me on my insurance for
this 7 to 1 for 8 MRI of the lower back
you can ask that over and over and over
again you can also say what would the
cash price be for that and we suggest
that people try to get that in writing
if they can if you can't get it in
writing you can also ask for somebody's
name phone number and take notes right
take notes take take take advice from
two reporters take notes so that later
when you say no so-and-so quoted me this
price you know when they say well who
did you talk to you'll know who you talk
to and you can say I talked to them on
you know September 29th at 10:30 in the
morning and her name was Jeannie
whatever and yeah and we also suggest
that you call several places and if
people keep saying no just keep calling
until you find somebody who will tell
you because it's really important that
we make this normal behavior like
everybody should be able to know in
advance and the question is sort of will
not generate pressure if if people if in
the medical community were to become
accustomed to patients asking them for
the prices on thing which for the
longest time has not been the case right
but it's change we're not habituated to
asking prices but that's becoming more
of the very if that becomes more than
norm does that then create pressure
within the system as a whole for
everyone to become more price conscious
and ask okay why are we charging fifteen
thousand dollars for an MRI when
somebody else charges five hundred right
why is that well one of the reasons is
that if you're having a fifteen thousand
dollar MRI chances are it's in a
hospital pretty much every procedure
that you have in a hospital is more
expensive than it would be outside of
the hospital and we saw that when you
and your people surveyed for us the two
markets Dallas in San Francisco if you
go again to CBS news.com slash health
costs click through the disclaimer page
you know click on the share and search
prices on the button click through that
disclaimer page and then go to the site
you'll see on the right-hand side it
says you can search prices for our to
sample markets just go in there put in
for example of mammogram one for
MRI of the lower back yes 7 2 1 4 8 or
just put in MRI lower back in the in
it'll it'll bring up a drop-down menu
that you can pick something from and
click that pick up your zip code if
you're in the San Francisco Bay Area I
know you people will do this for sure
they're very data-intensive out there
and just read that just check out the
prices because when you start scrolling
down it'll give you a list of prices
that the surveyors found and then on the
left-hand side please go in and share
your prices with us again CBS News comm
slash health costs and and a reminder
that you can also email us the email is
health costs at CBS news.com and please
feel free to email your questions or you
know tweet to us hit us up on Facebook
etc and and and participate because
we're kind of crowdsourcing to let other
people know around the country sort of
educate all of us as to what you're
paying if you live in a different part
of the country we want to hear from you
no matter where you live because the
insurance prices that you pay are not
public they're not public as we
mentioned in our segment this morning at
CBS this morning these negotiations go
on between insurance companies and
hospitals and providers and guess what
the only way you find out about those
prices typically is to be a patient with
that insurance going to that doctor so
we want to know from you hey what did
you wind up paying what are the weird
stories you had that maybe we should
look into what we think of our database
is something like a mash-up of kayak and
the Waze traffic app so we're using
reported data and crowd-sourced data to
shed light on the mysteries of health
care costs yeah it's not look it's not
at all for one solution guys I mean
obviously you're not gonna fix the
healthcare system with a few price lists
and it's but it's in the interest of hey
we want to find out what's going on
bring transparency to the market and
learn more about how it operates and
we're gonna have and we're gonna do that
with your help because you guys have
more power than all of us put together
all right well well see you soon cbsn
yes enough paid on something special so
yeah updates updates updates comment
updates come alright goodies thank you
thank you